ابلغ ديوان الرئاسه الاسرائيليه مكتبه
زعيم اللكود بنيامين نتنياهو قرار الرئيس
يسحاقد سوك تكليفه بتشكيل الحكومه جاء
القرار افرحوا سنه على توصيه 64 نائبا في
الكنيسه الجديد بذلك وكان يرتب قد اشار
الى ان ملف القدس وامكانيه توزيع اليمنيه
المتطرف اعتمر بن كثير ستشكل تحديا كبيرا
للحكومه المرتقبه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذكر خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف سيتعاطى نتنياهو
بعد تكليفه لتشكيل الحكومه الاسرائيليه مع
التحفظات بشان موقفه من القدس وامكانيه
تعيين بن كفير وزيرا فيها واي ردود فعل
يمكن توقعها من البيت الابيض وداخل الساحل
الفلسطينيه بمستوياتها المسلحه والسياسيه
على تركيبه وسياساته حكومه اقصى اليمين
المرتقبه في اسرائيل واي مصيرا ينتظر جهود
السلام في الشرق الاوسط وحكومه نتنياهو
التي كانت حكومته السابقه قد سقطت بفعل
سياسات يتعلق اهمها بملف القدس
[موسيقى]
كومه توصف بانها ستكون فيما يبدو الاكثر
يمينيه في تاريخ اسرائيل هي تلك التي
يستعد زعيم اللكود بنيامين نتنياهو
لتشكيلها بعد ان حصل على توصيه من 64
نائبا في الكود بذلك وعلى تكليف من قبل
الرئيس الاسرائيلي بتاليفها وقبل ان يذهب
نتنياهو الى ديوان الرئاسه ليتسلم كتاب
التكليف اشد الجدل حول سياسات الحكومه
المرتقبه خاصه اذا املف القدس وكذلك بشان
تركيبتها الوزاريه في ظل تطلع قاده من
اليمين المتطرف بينهم ثمار بن كثير لحقائب
مهمه والصدحافظات داخل اسرائيل تشتد بقوه
في اروقه البيت الابيض وفي ظل الرفض داخل
الساحه الفلسطينيه التي تشهد تصاعدا في
وتيره واشكال المقاومه للاحتلال
الاسرائيلي خاصه في صيغتها المسلحه وستكون
امام نتنياهو مهلت ثمانيه 20 يوما لعرض
حكومته على الهيئه العامه للكنيست لنيل
الثقه وهي قابله للتمديد 14 يوما ورجعت
مصادر صحفيه في اسرائيل ان يعمل بنيامين
نتنياهو على عرض توليفته الجديده خلال
الاسبوع المقبل مع التئام الكنيست في اولى
جلساته يوم الثلاثاء
وكانت وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه قد سرب
التسجيلا صوتيا للرئيس اسحاق هيرسون قال
فيه ان العالم باسره مبزوع من عضو الكنيسه
المتطرف اعتمار
بعد ما ظن ان الميكروفون امامه قد اغلق ان
الحكومه القادمه قد تواجه مشكله بشان
المسجد الاقصى
مشكله مع جمال الهيكل هذا موضوع حديث جدا
اعلم ولكن لديكم شريك كل من حولنا وكل
العالم مفزوع وانا قلت له ذلك وهذا ليس
للنشر لا اريد ان افتاء الى المشاكل
واعتقد انكم تتحلون بالمسؤوليه
لكنه اصبح اكثر اعتدالا
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا في البدايه من
مدينه حيفا الكاتب والمحلل السياسي سيد
الشيخ
من اجل تشكيل حكومته
المقبله هل من معلومات عن شكل هذه الحكومه
مع توقع مثلا
هو وغيره بحقائب مهمه وزاريه
طبعا يتحدثون عن اقامه وتشكيل حكومه جديده
في اسرائيل مبنيه ومعتمده على الاحزاب
الدينيه اليمنيه المتطرفه فيها بينج فير
والسموتريج الذين الذين يمثلان الحركه
الاستيطانيه باكملها حتى اكثر تترسا من
سموتش الذي شارك هذا الاسبوع في ذكرى رحيل
الخانكهانه التي كان رئيس حركه تسمى بحركه
ارهابيه في الولايات المتحده واوروبا شارك
في هذه الذكر هذا الاسبوع وهو يطالب
بوزاره الامن الداخلي يريد ان يكون
المسؤول عن قوات الشرطه الداخليه وال-
ربما التي موجوده ايضا في المناطق
الفلسطينيه هذا هو
المطلبتش من جانبه لا يطالب بمنسب وزير
الامان او الدفاع يريد ان يسيطر على ما
يقوم به جيش هذا الوزير الذي هو كمان في
النظام الاسرائيلي المسؤول عن ما يجري في
المناطق الفلسطينيه
مثل هذه الحقائب التي يعني يتطلع اليها
الطرفان
اولا اعتقد انهم يحاول سيحاول ان يمتنع من
دخول السماترتش الى وزاره الامن والى همم
كمان كثير ولكن
نتنياهم بحاجه الى هاتين الشخصيتين لكي
يكون هو المعتدل في هذه الحكومه هو دائما
هذا اسلوبنا ثاني يوم من جهه هناك
المتطرفين وهو يسوق نفسه كانه الاكثر
اعتدالا
نتنياهو نعم بحاجه اليهما في الحكومه
وسيكون جزء في هذه الحكومه بنهايه المنطقه
اعتقد انه يفضل ان يحافظ على الوزارات
السياديه المهمه لشخصيات من الكود التي
تكون ربما اكثر تحت السيطالته ولكن همم
يجب ان نذكر في هذه النقطه ايضا انه ما هو
اكثر اهميه هو وزاره العدل لانه يريد ان
يلغي محاكم ايه ويغير ويحد من صلاحيات
المحكمه العليا في الثانيه داخل
وفي
الاسرائيليه وايضا هناك تحفظات ومخاوف
ايضا ربما يجري الحديث عنها في الولايات
المتحده همم من توزيع
هاتين شخصيتين ومن الميول اليمنيه
المتطرفه للحكومه المقبله هل نتنياهو على
استعداد للاخذ همم بمثل هذه التحفظات بعين
الاعتبار اثناء عمليه تشكيل الحكومه
المرتقبه
نعم وهو يستغل هذه الضغوطات لكي يؤثر
عليهما على
ويقول لهم لا نستطيع ان يعطيكم وزاره
الامن الداخلي لا نستطيع ان نعطيكم وزاره
الامن فيمن المفاوضات دايما نتنياهو
يستعمل كل العوامل المختلفه ولكنه يفضل ان
يكون في هذه الحكومه وهو معني ان يكون في
هذه الحكومه المفاوضات معهما ااه يعني ومع
كل لحظه اصلا تجري على قدم وساكت اعتقد
انه
يحاول ان يبني الحكومه القادمه هو واعد
جدا نتنه ليس من هو اكثر
الضغوطات الخارجيه هو ياخذ كل الاعتبارات
هو ياخذ كل شيء في عيني الاعتبار ولكن
بالاخر بنجر
سيكون عنصر يعني كل واحد منهم عنصر مهم
جدا في الحكومه شكرا من مدينه حيفا
السياسي
رحبوا بضيفينا لمزيد من النقاش من رام
الله دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ومن واشنطن
السفير في جاكراولي المتحدث السابق باسم
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه مرحبا بكما
سياترو ابدا معك كيف تواكب واشنطن تكليف
من نتنياهو بتشكيل الحكومه حكومه توصف
بينها ستكون الاكثر يمينيه في تاريخ
اسرائيل مع وجوه مثل ابن كثير
الو
تشكيله الحكومه الاسرائيليه وننظر ايضا
الى تشكيله الحكومه الامريكيه
هنا سيكون هناك بعض الاثار فيما يتعلق
بادارهما مع القضايا المتعلقه
باسرائيل والمنطقه والفلسطينيين في
المستقبل ولكن بكل تاكيد الولايات المتحده
على وعي وادراك بطبيعته تحالف او اختلاف
نتنياهو
والتناقضات الموجوده داخلها ولكن بدون شك
سوف ينتظرون ليره كيف يمكن ان تنبثق
السياسات عن هذه الحكومه ومن ثم سوف
يتصرفون حسب ما هو مطلوب بعد ذلك
الى اي درجه ستشكل مثل هذه الحكومه
المقبله تحديا كبيرا على الساحه
الفلسطينيه بكل مستوياتها السياسيه
المقسمه والشعبيه ايضا
[موسيقى]
مش بس الحكومي الاشد تطرفا وعنصريه في
الواقع الموضوع ليس موضوع الحكومه
بالموضوع كل المجتمع الاسرائيلي الذي قرر
ان يصوت للفساد وللفاشيه هذه حكومه تضم
وستضن همم وزراء فاشيين بالمعنى الحرفي
للكلمه وبالتالي ستكون فعلا الحكومه
الاكثر اجراما ولكن ايضا الحكومه
الصهيونيه الاكثر انكشافا امام العالم
بمعنى ان السمات الارهابيه التي استخدم ضد
الفلسطينيين منذ عام 1948 وجرى التغطيه
عليها الان مكشوفه للعالم بشكل واضح طبعا
هاي تشكل تحدي كبير اولا هم سيعملوا على
توسيع والتصعيد الاستيطان ثانيا سيعمل على
ضمه تهويد الضفه الغربيه بكاملها وسيحاول
ان يمارس عمليه التهويد داخل المسجد
الاقصى وقد يفجر ذلك المنطقه بكاملها
اضيفي الى ذلك ان واقع ما ينشا الواقع
الذي ينشا يعني هو موت ما سمي بحل
الدولتين
وموت كل النهج الذي قام على مبدا التفاوض
وامكانيه الوصول الى حل وسط بين
الفلسطينيين والحركه الصهيونيه وطبعا هذا
يمثل المجتمع الدولي ايضا
للضيفي ااه سيد بيجو كراولي ملف القدس
طالما كان عقده المنشار في
لدى حكومه ايضا ضمن مفاوضات السلام برايك
كيف
النهج الذي سيكون عليه داخل هذه الحكومه
مع المخاوف همم من خلال ما يصرح به هؤلاء
ابن كثير مثلا بخصوص القدس وسكان القدس
والاقتحامات المتسلسله
والمستمره التي يخطط لها
ابو صياد
هذا الامر على مدى اشهر بان التوترات
متزايده داخل القدس الشرقيه والضفه
الغربيه وعلى المره ان ينظر الى تركيبته
هذه الحكومه القادمه
بقوه ضد اي عنف قد يندلعن الخطر هنا
اس بي اهو
والفلسطينيين والاولاد المتحده هي انه
علينا ننظر الى هذا الامر بصراحه وان
نتحدث عن امكانيه وجود صراع وهذا اكبر
احتماليه من حدوث مفاوضات اذا فسوف يكون
من المهم لحكومه نتنياهو ان تدير هذا
الامر وهذا امر ايضا مهم للسلطه
الفلسطينيه ان تقوم بافضل ما بوسعها في
الجانب الامني والولايات المتحده سوف تفعل
كل ما بوسعها بقيت محاوله ابقاء التوترات
اقل مما هي كما رايناها في الفتره الاخيره
تزداد
الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق هيرتزقه
اثناء له بقت عالمي المتطرف قائلا موضوع
جبل الهيكل وهو يقصد المسجد الاقصى يثير
تساؤلات في العالم الاسلامي وحساسيه لدى
شرك في السلامه واضافها هيرزق متوجها
بكلامه لبن كثير هناك صوره معينه لك
ولحسبك وانا اقول هذا بكل امانه تبدو
مثيره للقلق من نواحن همم كثيره السيد
مصطفى البرغوثي ما نوع برايك المقاربه
التي
سيتم الذهاب اليها فلسطينيه مع مثل هذا
التحدي والمخوف التي هي موجوده ايضا لدى
الاوساط الاسرائيليه ليست فقط تخص الشعب
الفلسطيني وايضا الخارج
علينا ان نتذكر ان القضيه الفلسطينيه
عمرها 74 عام
والاحتلال للضفه الغربيه وغذي عمره 54 عام
او 55 عام والعالم ينتظر ويتفرج واسرائيل
مستمر في الاستيطان ولولا سكوت العالم على
اسرائيل لما جاء هذا اليمين العنصر
الاجرام المتطرف الى الحكم الرد الفلسطيني
يجب ان يكون واضحا باب المفاوضات اغلق
الحديث عن عمليه سلام كلام فارغ اليوم ليس
امام الفلسطينيين الا ثلاث خطوات اساسيه
يجب اتخاذها اولا انهاء الانقسام الداخلي
فورا وتوحيد الصف الفلسطيني على برنامج
ونهج وطني كفاحي مقاوم مقاوم لهذه الحكومه
الاجراميه العنصريه وللاحتلال ونظام
الابارتيد الذي تدرسه ثانيا لابد من فضح
هذه الحكومه ومطالبه العالم اولا العربي
والعالم باسره بمقاطعتها وتصنيف حزب كبير
باعتباره حزبا فاشيا ارهابيا تصنيفه كحرك
ارهابيه وهذا قابل للتحقيق الامر الثالث
يجب اعطاء الفرصه ايضا للشعب الفلسطيني ان
يختار قياداته بحريه وديمقراطيه وان يختار
ايضا خطه بحريه وديمقراطيه اذا كان
الجمهور الاسرائيلي صوت للفاشيه والعنصريه
فمن حق الشعب الفلسطيني هل يصوت لنهج
المقاومه وان يجدد قياداته وان يفتح الباب
للعناصر الشابه لذلك هذه هي الخطوات
الثلاثه
مهمه جدا
السياسي هل سينحوا اكثر باتجاه مقاربات
همم
ذهاب بمسار السلام التي طالما نادى بها
امنه سيذهب فعليا مثلا عمليه توحيد حاله
الانقسام طالما بان هذا التحدي هو التحدي
صارخ امامه بمثل هذه الحكومه اليمنيه
المتطرفه التي تشمل الصهيونيه الدينيه
يعني لو تواصلوا الحديث عن عمليه السلام
لقرنين من الزمان لن يحدث شيء الابواب
اغلقت اليوم مش بس اتفاق وصلوا قتلوا
نتنياهو بل دفن ايضا وبالتالي ذلك الخيار
فشل يجب ان يعترف يعني يعترف اصحاب هذه
النهج انه البناء كل شيء على المفاوضات
والتفاهم مع الحركه الصهيونيه فشل فشلا
تاما وليس امامنا كشعب فلسطيني الان الا
نهج المقاومه والكفاح اسرائيل لم تفهم الا
لغه القوه ولن يتغير شيء الا بتغيير ميزان
القوه واول خطوه في اتجاه تغيير ميزان
القوه توحيد الصف الفلسطيني والثاني خطوه
التوحد على نهج المقاومه والكفاح وثالث
خطوه اعطاء الشعب حقه في الاختيار هذه هي
الخيارات اللي امامنا وانا بقول عنا الان
فرصه عظيمه على الصعيد الدولي لعزل وتعريه
نظام الابارتيد العنصري ومحاصالته اليوم
لدينا وسائل كثيره لم نكن نستطيع ان
نستعملها ونستطيع ان نستعملها
همم كيف ستتعامل الاداره الامم الامريكيه
ما حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو همم عمليا على
الارض في الخطوات همم في ضمن ملفات التي
تشكل ملفات اساسيه في علاقتها مع هذه
الحكومه في ما يخص الصراع الفلسطيني
الاسرائيلي
بعضهم بطريقه جيده وسوف يحاول الالقاء على
علاقه
بينما ان العلاقات لن تكون كما هي كانت
بدايه
ولا بدايه التوتر ايا كان اوباما في الحكم
اداره ايضا بالتالي سوف تعبر عن القلق
بالاعتماد على اي شخص يحصل على اي حقيبه
وزاريه ومن هو همم في هذا الاختلاف يكونوا
متشددا
وقضيه الامن من سيحصل عليها وملف الامن
والولايات المتحده سوف تحاول العمل حول
هذه القضيه من كان وزير خارجيه لم يتعامل
مع الحكومه الامريكيه مباشره ووزير
والدفاع عن قام بذلك اذا كان الثانيه وعلى
وعيالك وسوف يحاول ان يتجنب القيام بامور
من شانه ان تشكل توتر في العلاقات
بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل بشكل كبير
ولكن علينا ان همم وعلينا ان نتفق مع
الدكتور البرغوثي بانه ليس هناك فرص لدعم
عمليه السلام قدما في هذا الوقت اذا
التركيز بالتالي لاداره بايدنس سوف يكون
العمل مع اسرائيل بغيه اداره الوضع الحالي
بافضل طريقه ممكنه ومحاوله منع الامور منه
هذا ليس توجهها لجعل الامور افضل في الوقت
الحاضر
صوره ممكنه بين البيت الابيض وحكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو وهي بحاجه ربما لاوراق ما
نوع الاوراق
التي لدى همم البيت الابيض من اجل ضبط
ايقاع العلاقه مع الطرف همم الاسرائيلي في
هذه الحكومه الجديده سيد كراولي
انت في جامعه القاهره
في الانتخابات النصفيه في الحقيقه يعطي
بايدي بعض النفوذ والقوه نتنياهو
كان معدان
ولكن
ايضا رغم عوده
فهذه الحكومه ضعيفه سياسيا ومقيده في ما
يمكن ان تفعله اذا
ما ارادت البقاء فعليها ان تجد سبيلا لكي
تدير العناصر المتطرفه وان تقدم التنازلات
بطريقه قد لا تقوم بها في العاده مره اخرى
هذا لا يعني باننا سوف نقوم بحل التوترات
الموجوده حاليا بين الجانب الاسرائيلي
والفلسطيني لن نكون قادرين على فعل هذا في
وقت قريب ولهذا اعتقد انه سوف يكون هناك
حظر في كيفيه التعامل مع هذه القضايا
وايضا ان كان لان اضيف
كبادرا من بن جميل نتنياهو قام باصدارها
وهو اهتمامه
بتوسيع التطبيع في العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
بين اسرائيل ودول عربيه اخرى وهذا سوف
يكون صعب القيام به
في عجال اريد ان اذهب في ما تبقى من الوقت
للدكتور مصطفى الدكتور مصطفى ما نوع اللغه
التي
تكون هي
موقع التعامل ما بين الشعب الفلسطيني
وحكمه نتنياهو ما بين الحاله السياسيه
الفلسطينيه وحكمه اليوم
اولا علينا ان نلاحظ انه من المخاطر
القائمه مش بس ان ان يستمر القمع القائم
حاليا بل ان يتصاعد اكثر
الامر الثاني احتمالات المواجهه لن تشمل
فقط الفلسطينيين هناك خطر كبير الان ان
تحدث مواجهه مع لبنان هناك خطر كبير ان
تحدث حرب جديده على قطاع غزه هناك خطر
كبير ان تتفجر العلاقات مع يعني او
المواجهه مع ايران لذلك كل هذه المخاطر
الموجوده في ظل هذه الحكومه اما فلسطينيا
فطبعا ليس امامنا الا ان نواجه هذه
الحكومه السبيل الوحيد هو مواجهتها واحسن
وسيله لتحقيق ذلك توحيد الصف الوطني على
برنامج للمواجهه في همم هؤلاء يعني تخيل
انت بنج فير بعد انتخابه ماذا فعل ذهب الى
تابين كهنا وحتى في الخارجيه الامريكيه
وصفوا ذلك بانه عمل اذا لدينا فرصه
الان لعزل هذه الحكومه وليس التعاطي معها
ويجب العمل لايضا الغاء التطبيع الذي جرى
الذي استخدم ضد القضيه الفلسطينيه
كخنجر في ظهر القضيه الفلسطينيه هذا يمكن
الان الحد منه بتعريه هذه الحكومه وفضلها
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه وايضا في من
واشنطن سفير بيجي كراولي المتحدث السابق
باسمي وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
الى هناك تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء بحول الله
[موسيقى]